stub um is a ticketing company that was
born out of Stanford Business School by
two guys Eric Baker who the story is
about and Jeff lured who is his former
co-founder things initially started well
they had this really great idea and they
entered it in the Stanford business plan
competition which takes place every year
and out of like 50 or 60 nominations
they were named one of six finalists but
on the day that they were supposed to
present at the finals the two of them
decided not to show up because they
decided the idea was so good that they
didn't want anyone to know about it so
they've launched her Jeff actually
worked on it full-time while Eric wasn't
sure he wanted to commit so he stayed
back at Stanford Business School and as
a result of that Jeff had a little bit
more equity and when Eric finally joined
full-time a couple of years later the
two of them butted heads and basically
Eric got kicked out it's not that
unusual that co-founders butt heads but
what's really interesting is that after
Eric Baker got fired he still had a
pretty big equity stake in StubHub but
almost immediately after he left that
company he secretly launched this new
company in Europe called via gogo which
launched in 2006 and basically did the
exact same thing as Sub Pop just on a
different continent so last fall Eric
Baker decided that he wanted to take his
story full circle and he put up about
four when we spoke on the phone
Eric was super bullish about the live
ticketing industry he literally said to
me there's never been a better time to
be in live events of course what he
didn't realize is that just a couple of
months later the pandemic was going to
start bubbling up first in Asia by the
time he closed the deal it was already
expanding out of Asia into other parts
of the world and within just a couple of
weeks after he finalized the deal
the
our live events industry completely blew
up and stuff up in Vigo whose revenues
are down at least 90% in retrospect
obviously it's very easy to say that
Baker's timing was terrible that he made
one of the worst time deals in history
if you just look at the numbers on a
very straight basis it's hard to get in
his head
clearly the w-h-o had already labeled
the pandemic a global health emergency
when he closed the deal so it should
have been on his radar whether or not he
should have known how big the pandemic
was going to get or how much it was
going to crush his businesses is I think
a little bit harder to say the really
big question is what happens next it
looks like iego going StubHub are going
to be some of the last businesses in the
country if not the world to rebound from
this endemic because they rely not just
on live events which requires tons of
people sitting next to each other but
also on excess demand for those events
which causes people to go to the
secondary market rather than buying from
stadiums directly that's a really long
way away the reason I found this story
so interesting was that Eric was trying
to close the loop on his own circle and
sort of write his own destiny it was a
story about Redemption and about revenge
to a certain extent and clearly after
trying to take his fate under his own
control the world changed around him and
he had no ability to control it and his
businesses were fundamentally altered
and damaged so what I found interesting
is that here's a man who's trying to
control his story and the world is
telling him not so fast
you